[Music]
hey everyone
welcome again our installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing severus snape
the prisoner of azkaban and the
marauders more specifically
we're going to be taking a look at a
scene in the prison of azkaban
where severus snape who had not
encountered any of the mardis for many
many years
encounters the marauders map what's so
curious about snape's encounter with the
map
however that he didn't seem to recognize
it it all starts one night with harry
scouring the hogwarts corridors trying
to find peter pettigrew
however not long into his manhunt
harry's plan is torted
when snape appears of course from here
it doesn't take long for snape
who knows that harry is up to no good to
snatch the map
attempting to reveal its contents let me
see
let me see he muttered taking out his
wand and smoothing the map out on his
desk
reveal your secret he said touching the
wand to the parchment
to this however the map simply insults
snape
eventually lupin is brought into the mix
and snape still doesn't seem to
understand
what the map is lupin snape called into
the fire
i want a word utterly bewildered harry
stared at the fire
a large shape had appeared in it
revolving very fast
seconds later professor lupin was
clambering out of the fireplace
brushing ash off his shabby robes you
called severus
said lupin mildly i certainly did said
snape
his face contorted with fury as he
strode back to his desk
i have just asked potter to empty his
pockets
he was carrying this snape pointed at
the parchment
on which the words of moony wormtail
padfoot and prongs
were still shining an odd closed
expression appeared on lupin's face
well said snape given that by this point
snape had seen the nicknames of the four
boys that used to torment him
it should be safe to assume that snape
would know what the map was
however snape continues to question
lupin about what
exactly the map is did snape not
recognize the code names
lupin continued to stare at the map
harry had the impression that lupin was
doing some very quick thinking
well says nip again this parchment is
plainly
full of dark magic this is supposed to
be your area of expertise
lupin why do you imagine potter got such
a thing
lupin looked up and by the merest half
glance in harry's direction
warned him not to interrupt full of dark
magic
he repeated mildly do you really think
so severus
it looks to me as though it is merely a
piece of parchment that insults anybody
who reads it
childish but surely not dangerous i
imagine how i got it from a joke shop
indeed said snape his jaw had gone rigid
with anger
you think a joke shop could supply him
with such a thing you don't think it's
more likely that he got it directly from
the
manufacturers harry didn't understand
what snape was talking about nor
apparently did lupin you mean by mr
wormtail
or one of these people he said harry do
you know any of these men
no said harry quickly you see severus
said lupin turning back to snape it
looks like a zonker product to me
here's what i think snape knew that it
was an object that belonged to the
marauders
and he knew who to trace it to he knew
that lupin was involved with this map in
some way
this is why he says you don't think it
more likely that he got it directly from
the manufacturers
however that certainly doesn't mean
snape would know what the map actually
was
the map was wiped clean before snape got
to it
and it was effectively designed to repel
people like snape
as smart as snape was this was an object
that he knew
very little about and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time your wizard harry